hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
from mkbhd and i am back with another hd
video and this one is going to be tech
channel of the week number five and this
is a relatively new series of videos
that goes up every week or weekend or a
monday like this case and um this one
as you can see by the title is going to
be mtp flyers is the tech channel of the
week and uh this is his youtube chat
youtube page or channel right here um
and basically what they have or what he
has going on is one man show and he does
a lot of um iphone and ipod actually
just iphone cases and he's about to hit
18 000 channel views um so basically if
we scroll down here he's got a few cool
playlists uh a few collaborations a few
youtube reviewer interviews and he
interviewed the punisher 08 if you
haven't already checked out his channel
and a few youtube reviewer videos
as we keep scrolling down here we'll see
he has 88 video
uploads he has a few hardware videos as
well as a few like app reviews which i
would call software videos so if you go
to his most viewed video page um you can
see a new ipod shuffle giveaway which i
was unfortunately a bit late for
but yeah he does have a lot of a mix of
um
cases and accessories for iphones that
you guys might want to check out so
let's go back to his channel page here
right now he is gaining
very quickly on two thousand subscribers
so an early congrats to you i guess on
the 2000 subscriber mark and you can
always see on his channel which i'm
actually starting to do uh the videos
that are upcoming this week so
apparently he's gonna have about five
more videos up this week including a uh
an interview um so you guys might want
to check that out
um
so yeah uh i have that actually written
on my channel page instead of in my
channel description uh so i think we can
get him to 2000 subscribers um he does
have a lot of cool videos and he uploads
uh kind of regularly and i guess you can
tell he's a flyers fan by his um by his
logo and by his name
uh but that's basically it for this
channel a nice little background there
with little apple logos um but yeah
that's it thanks uh thanks for watching
this tech channel of the week number
five again this is a pretty new series
so i'm still checking out all the
channels
every channel that does subscribe to me
i go ahead and check out their channel
and leave a comment saying you know
thanks for subscribing and everything
and sometimes i see some really nice
channels out there and i'll subscribe to
them as well
so thanks for checking out this tech
channel of the week number five mtp
flyers his link will be in the
description and that is it thanks for
watching guys have a nice night peace